we're told point a is at negative 1
comma 4 and Point C is at 4 comma
negative 6 find the coordinates of point
B on segment line segment AC such that
the ratio of a B to AC is 3 to 5 so
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
alright now let's work through this
together and to help us visualize let's
plot these points so first let us plot
point a which is at negative 1 comma 4
so negative 1 comma 1 2 3 4 so that
right over there is point a and then
let's think about Point C which is at 4
comma negative 6 so 1 2 3 4 comma
negative 6 negative 1 negative 2
negative 3 negative 4 negative 5
negative 6 just like that and so the
segment AC I get my ruler tool out here
segment AC is going to look like that
and the ratio between the distance of A
to B and a to C is 3 to 5 or another way
to think about it is B is going to be
three fifths along the way from A to C
now the way that I think about it is in
order to be three fifths along the way
from A to C you have to be three fifths
along the way in the x-direction
and three fifths along the way in the
y-direction so let's think about the
x-direction first we are going from x
equals negative 1 to x equals four to go
from this point to that point our change
in X is one two three four five and so
if we want to go three fifths of that we
went a total of five three fifths of
that is going just three so that is
going to be B's x-coordinate and then we
can look on the y coordinate side to go
from A to C we are going from four to
negative six so we're going down by one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
and so three fifths of ten would be six
so bees coordinate is going to be one
two three four five six down so just
like that we were able to figure out the
X and the y coordinates for point B
which would be right over here and you
could look at this directly and say look
B is going to be have the coordinates
this looks like this is 2 comma negative
2 which we were able to do with the
graph paper so another way you could
think about it even algebraically is the
coordinates of B we could think about it
as starting with the coordinates of a so
negative 1 comma 4 but we're going to
move 3/5 along the way in each of these
dimensions toward C so it's going to be
plus 3/5 times how far we've gone in the
X direction so in the X direction to go
from A to C we're going from negative 1
to 4 and so that distance is 4 minus
negative 1 and this of course is going
to be equal to 5 and then on the Y
dimension this is going to be our a's
y-coordinate plus 3/5 times the distance
that we travel in the y direction and
here we're going from 4 to negative 6 so
if we say negative 6 minus 4 that is
negative 10 and so the coordinates of B
are going to be negative 1 plus 3/5
times 5 is going to be plus 3 and then 4
plus 3/5 times negative 10 well 3/5
times negative 10 is negative 6 and so
that gets us to comma negative 2 and we
are done which is exactly what we got
right over there